The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So I think we have
a bit of background in mind.
So now I'm going to summarize
this discussion, and start
asking about how do we go about
answering some of the
questions that have
come about?
So at the end of last lecture,
we were left with our S-shaped
curve, and saying that whether
or not there would be a
poverty trap was really
dependent on the shape of the
curve that relates income today
to income tomorrow.
And we gave sent out examples
where it could go one way or
the other, or it could be that
its S shape, it could be that
it's increasing but
inverted L-shape.
And then one of you asked
the question,
well, how do we know?
How do we even get about--
how do we get to know the
shape of the curve?
This is not a question that
is going to be solved
theoretically.
The debate we just had a moment
ago suggested it won't
be solved theoretically.
Because, for example, take the
question of whether if I give
you a bed net for free today,
you're less likely to buy the
next one tomorrow.
It depends on whether the
entitlement effect is more
important than the
loaning effect.
And how will I know that?
There is no way for me
to know it without
looking at the data.
And the question is, what's a
good way to look at the data?
And today, we're going to look
at one such way, which is a
way which is increasingly often
used by development
economists, by policy makers,
and which is the main approach
that we are using in the Poverty
Action Lab, which is
the idea of on randomized
evaluation.
So we'll start with our
malaria example.
I'm going to use the malaria
example, because we had the
debate, so we know the question
we're asking.
I'm going to use that
as our example.
But, of course, the point I'm
making now are important
methodological points as well.
So what are we talking about?
We're talking about a pretty
important thing.
Almost 900,000 people die of
malaria every year, give and
take, most of them in Africa,
most of them under five.
That's the biggest cause
of under-five
mortality in the world.
Incidentally, you want to take
every single statistic with a
big pinch of salt, because it's
not that all the malaria
cases are recorded--
a lot of people who are not
really diagnosed of malaria
and are told to be dead of
malaria, so it could be a
gross overestimate or a
gross underestimate.
But I think it's fair to say
it's a lot of people, one way
or the other.
As we discussed, malaria is
transmitted by mosquitoes who
carry the parasite from an
infected person to an
uninfected person,
mainly at dusk.
So sleeping under a bed net,
particularly a bed net which
has insecticide woven into the
fiber of the bed net is an
effective way to prevent
mosquito bites, and therefore
to prevent the transmission
of malaria.
And one thing that no one said,
which was important, is
that there is two effects of
sleeping under a bed net.
If you already don't have
malaria, you're less likely to
catch it, because the mosquitoes
can't bite you.
So this is a direct benefit
that benefits you.
So when making the decision to
buy or not buy a bed net when
making the decision to use the
bed net or not to use it, you
are going to take this direct
benefit into account, right?
But then there is another
benefit which is the
externality, which is an
indirect effect, which is, if
you already have malaria,
someone else is less likely to
get it because they don't
first bite you
and then bite them.
And this benefit, unless
you're an incredibly
socially-minded person, is a
benefit you don't take into
account when buying
your bed net.
Because you don't care.
It's not you.
It's someone else.
But as society, we are trying to
maybe adjust the individual
behavior to the social
benefit.
There's one more thing which is
important for us to keep in
mind, which is this externality
is not linear.
So it could be that the
externality is linear, which
is one more person who sleeps
under a bed net, say half a
fewer percent is infected.
So it could be like the more
bed nets you have, the less
malaria you have, but in
a disproportional way.
But it turns out that it's
not proportional.
The reason why it's not
proportionally is because once
about half the population sleeps
under the bed net, you
have something called hard
immunity, which is that the
mosquitoes don't have time to
bite someone else before
either the mosquito or
the parasite dies.
So if you manage to cover about
half of your population,
you don't even need to
carry the other half.
I mean, it's better,
but they already
benefit almost as much.
So the externality benefits are
like this, if you want.
They're like, first they're
linear, and then at some
point, they have a big jump in
the externality benefits.
And then again, going from
80% to 85%, maybe less.
So that means that this would
need to be reminding you of
the S-shaped thing, which is
there will be a distinct
advantage in terms of cost per
malaria averted, the benefit
of going from a coverage of 25%
to 30% of the population
are going to be lower than the
benefit of going, say, from
45% to 50%.
Because when you go from 45%
to 50%, you're in the zone
where every extra bed net is
really helping a huge deal.
So that is going to
be relevant when
we do the cost benefit.
So that's the case
for bed nets.
So now, if we were traditional
economists, we would make a
traditional economic argument,
which is to say, there is an
externality.
Whenever there is an
externality, we want to try to
do use prices or taxes to align
the private incentive
with the public incentive.
That's why, for example,
we would like to have a
congestion charge in London, or
we have a congestion charge
in London to make it expensive
to drive your car in London,
in the center of London, because
when you drive your
car in the center of London,
that's a pain
for everybody else.
That could be one of the reasons
why we have taxes on
cigarettes, that smokers impose
an externality on the
rest of the people, here both
because of secondhand smoking,
and because they
get sick a lot.
So you would think that society
has a right to impose
a tax on them to try and
discourage them from smoking.
So by using prices and taxes is
where you can try and align
the private incentive to
the social benefit.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you do community
incentives, like you tell the
community if everyone uses their
bed nets as bed nets,
you'll give the community a
certain number of fishing nets
so that people will encourage
or force other
people to use bed nets?
ESTHER DUFLO: Right.
So one way is the prices, but
another way could be to have
community incentives.
Indonesia has a program where
they are trying to give
community incentive so if, say
90% percent of the community
is immunized, and x percent to
the community is in school,
then they get some amount of
money to build a road, or an
irrigation project, or
something like that.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious.
How much is given in foreign
aid to fight malaria?
ESTHER DUFLO: That's an
excellent-- how much is given
in foreign aid to
fight malaria.
It's an excellent question, the
answer to which I don't
know off the top of my head,
but it's findable.
AUDIENCE: Because I was going
to ask if the cost of
providing a country with bed
nets is significantly less
than the cost of giving
[INAUDIBLE] money to fight
malaria, then I don't even
see why it's as big of a
debate as it is.
Clearly, they should figure out
what's the most effective
way to distribute the bed nets,
make sure [INAUDIBLE].
But the option of not giving
them just wouldn't make as
much sense, in terms of
cost [INAUDIBLE].
ESTHER DUFLO: Oh, I see.
So providing bed nets
would be part of the
budget of fighting malaria.
So your question is that, if
we're already spending so much
money on medicine against
malaria, we would really be
willing to spend a lot
of money on bed nets.
You're exactly right.
And I don't think the debate
is that we want to try and
save money on the bed nets.
I think the debate is always
about what's the best way to
get the money out.
So this would argue, so the
fact that the private
incentive to get your bed net
is low, would argue for
subsidizing the bed net, but
only if the private incentives
are not large enough that people
are already not buying
your bed net.
So suppose, for example, that
people hated being sick,
which, presumably, they do.
Then, they would get
the bed net anyway.
You would not need to subsidize
the bed net.
So there would not be an effect
of the price, because
the demand would be very
high at any price.
So the fact that there is
an externality justifies
subsidizing, to the extent that
the private incentives
are too small for people to want
to get them themselves.
Another traditional economics
argument would be the learning
argument that was made earlier,
which is that trying
your bed net once might give you
the experience of it, and
once you knew how it works,
and you know how well it
protects your children, you
might be more likely to get
the next one.
And then there is an argument
that mixes the two, which is
another externality argument,
which is, if try a bed net,
and I realize that it protects
my children and it's really
not so unpleasant, then maybe my
neighbors will also see my
bed net, and say, oh,
isn't this cool.
We want also a bed net.
So there is an externality in
my trying, potentially.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: But if you were
charged for bed nets and the
borrower that could, again, come
in to have the bed nets
[INAUDIBLE]?
ESTHER DUFLO: Yes.
So eventually, since there are
those contingent benefits,
someone who is very rational
might feel, already more than
50% bed nets in this
community.
I don't need to get
the next one.
So the private incentives
diminish as the coverage
increases, which makes it more
necessary either to subsidize
it even more, or to tax people
if they don't get a bed net.
So this is an argument that
is made for immunization.
So in this country, immunization
is compulsory for
a range of diseases.
Except if you really don't want
to do it because you have
some religious or whatever
reasons for not wanting to be
immunized, then you can say,
sorry, I refuse the
immunization.
And people worry that as
diseases such as polio, or
diphtheria, or pertussis, these
types of diseases become
less frequent, people don't have
the fear of getting those
diseases anymore, and they want
to free ride on the rest
of the community.
And that's, of course, bad,
because being 100% immunized
ensures that the disease
goes away.
As soon as a few people
are not immunized,
it could come back.
And so there is this tension
between once almost everyone's
immunized, your private
incentive to do
it are almost zero.
So you might need powerful
inducement to get to do it.
So those are the traditional
economic arguments.
These are your traditional
public finance--
let's use the prices.
That indicates that we should
subsidize the bed nets.
And by the way, there
is no reason to
stop at zero in principle.
We could pay people to use bed
nets, for that matter, if this
was the way to get the optimal
coverage in the community.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So one consideration
that comes to mind is if
there's a segment of the
population that is really,
really poor and cannot afford to
pay any amount for the bed
nets, whether they're subsidized
or not, those
people are also the least likely
to be able to pay for
health care should
they get malaria.
So they would have the greatest
risk for everyone
else and for themselves.
So wouldn't you want to try to
provide free bed nets for that
set of people, no matter what?
ESTHER DUFLO: Right, so that's
another consideration that you
might want to include, a
redistribution consideration,
which you might feel that people
who are particularly
poor might have a very high
private evaluation of the bed
nets, but might be credit
constrained and not be able to
get the bed net.
And those are the same people
who will also not be able to
cure themselves of malaria.
So here, that gives you
another argument for
subsidizing bed nets, which is
not an argument in terms of
disease eradication, but
an argument in terms of
redistribution between people.
So those are traditional
arguments.
They are taken, say, by Jeff
Sachs, or by the WHO, and say,
we should subsidize bed net
to a large extent, or
potentially, up to giving
them away for free.
And then we have the less
conventional economics, which
we discussed, which has the
argument that goes in the
opposite direction, or the
psychological sunk cost
effect, which is, you have to
pay for something to really
appreciate its value.
There is a selection effect
which is, if you give things
away for free, even people who
don't want it or who don't
want it for its legitimate use
are going to come and get it.
They're going to waste
a lot of bed nets.
And finally, the entitlement
effect, which counters the
learning effect, which is, once
you get something for
free, then you expect to get
it for free in the future.
And it might even have
contingent things, which is
you're not going to want to get
chlorine to purify your
water, unless someone
is giving it to you.
You're not going to want to
send your kids to school
unless they get a school meal,
other things like that, which
find that you become
dependent.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Couldn't you argue that it's not
sustainable, [INAUDIBLE]
long-term policy and exit
strategies, because if you're
[INAUDIBLE]
subsidizing and giving away bed
nets, you might crowd out
the private sector.
And you won't [INAUDIBLE] your
desired outcome, which is for
people to be using bed nets.
ESTHER DUFLO: So in the
traditional public finance
argument, why would you
ever want to stop to
subsidize the bed net?
AUDIENCE: Want to
not subsidize--
ESTHER DUFLO: Yeah.
Why would you ever want to stop,
given those arguments?
AUDIENCE: To create a market?
ESTHER DUFLO: Why would you?
Take, for example, immunization
in the US.
Immunization is subsidized
and compulsory.
Is there any plan to make
immunization not subsidized or
compulsory?
AUDIENCE: That's true.
ESTHER DUFLO: There's
no such plan.
This kind of argument would
tell you that you want to
subsidize forever, because the
private gains and the social
gains are not aligned for a
fundamental reason, which is
my being protected by a bed net
protects you as well, and
that's never going to change.
So in that sense, you're
not doing a policy
for the short run.
You're doing this policy
for the long run.
Now, again, we had this
discussion earlier, which is
the questions of who provides
the bed net, whether they can
be provided locally instead
of imported, are all very
legitimate questions, but in a
sense, unrelated to the price
you're going to charge.
So that's an excellent question,
because it comes
back all the time, which
is to say, oh, but
don't we want to exit?
Just think, whenever you want to
ask yourself this question
about sustainability,
ask yourself, why
would I want to exit?
Maybe I don't.
Maybe it is actually socially
efficient to subsidize
something for eternity, because
as Ben was saying, you
save on the cost of curing
people from malaria.
So the argument that goes
against giving people for free
are these arguments that giving
bed nets for free or
even subsidizing them is
counterproductive, in terms of
distributing bed nets.
It's counterproductive because
of the sunk cost effect,
because of the selection
effect, or because this
entitlement effect that then
nobody is ever going to want
to buy anything, either a bed
net or something else.
And these elements are
very reasonable.
Both sides of the arguments
are, in principle, very
reasonable.
And they might apply here.
We just don't know.
It's a very heated
policy debate.
The laws that are involved in
bed nets are nowhere near the
laws that are involved in oil or
anything, but it's still a
fair amount of dollars,
so people like those.
So there is a lot of debate.
So Jeff Sachs of the WHO relies
on the convention
economics argument to say
you should give the
bed nets for free.
Then you have people like Bill
Easterly or Dambisa Moyo, who
are making the argument based
on this entitlement effect,
sunk cost effect, the
development of market, to say
we shouldn't give
them for free.
And both arguments tell you,
in a sense, we know the
economics, and the answer
is obvious.
There is no reason
to find out.
And I think there is value in
both type of arguments that
they are making.
But there is no value
in this last one.
Because since there is value
in both arguments, we don't
know the answer.
The answer depends on the
balance of how they turn out
in the specific application
of bed nets.
So the true question we want to
ask is the extent to which
we should subsidize bed nets.
And for that, what do
we need to know?
Well, first we need to know
whether or not bed nets are
really price elastic.
So are we losing a lot of
coverage in terms of people
acquiring bed nets, if we start
selling them instead of
giving them for free.
Second question we need
to ask is the
immediate effect on use.
So is it the case that people
who pay for bed nets are more
likely to use it than people
who got it for free?
Third question is the
longer-term effect.
Will it wreck markets?
And for that, that's the
entitlement effect.
For people who get it for free,
in the future, are they
more or less likely
to buy one?
And for people who are around
them in the community--
this is something we didn't
discuss much, but if I'm
around you in the community,
and I see you having a free
bed net, it could affect
me in one of two ways.
I could say, first of all,
oh, she has a bed net.
That's really nice.
Her kids are doing well.
I'm going to get one too.
I could say, oh, she
got a free bed net.
Let me wait until I get--
I was going to buy a bed net,
but now I'm going to wait
until I get a free bed net.
And so I wasn't going to sell
a bed net, and now I'm going
to have give it for free.
So that's wasted money.
So again, we don't know
which way it cuts.
We have to look in practice.
And those questions are pretty
well-defined questions.
They are empirical questions
we could principally
bring an answer to.
There are a lot of anecdotes.
They are this one, which is bed
nets used as fishing nets.
That's a picture that was in the
Malaria Journal, so it's
all peer reviewed
and all that.
So this is the Easterly Dambisa
Moyo argument, that
you are going to see the used
as a fishing net, or wedding
veils, or what have you.
And then this is the other
argument, of the other
anecdote of the bed net being
nicely hanged in the room, and
the child, the healthy child
who slept in there
under the bed net.
So that's not too helpful.
So we want to go further
that the anecdote.
There are many anecdotes,
and they cut both ways.
How do we go further
than the anecdote?
So the first thing we could
do-- so suppose you
were given this job.
I tell you, find out for me
whether people who get their
bed nets for free are more
likely to use it as fishing
nets or more likely to
use them as bed nets.
And also, find out whether if I
distribute the bed nets for
free, I distribute many more
of them or I distribute the
same amount.
What would your first
response to what you
should go out and do?
AUDIENCE: Yeah?
I would find two similar
communities, and then
[INAUDIBLE]
give bed nets would be one, and
maybe help someone start a
small business of selling
bed nets in the other.
ESTHER DUFLO: So you would take
two similar communities,
and in once case, give bed
nets for free, and in one
case, start to sell them,
maybe by finding a small
business, or maybe importing
them to the village.
What would be an even---
we'll go back to that.
What would be an even easier,
even more immediate way to do
it that we could think of to
start with, if we needed to do
this quickly?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just look at the
communities where it is already.
ESTHER DUFLO: Right.
You would look at a community
where this is already in
place, and you would say, well,
in this community, the
bed nets are given for free, and
in this community, the bed
nets are sold.
Let me try my thing.
Yeah.
In this community, the bed
nets are given for free.
In this community, the
bed nets are sold.
First question, do I see more
bed nets where the bed nets
are not given for free?
Second question, do I see the
bed nets more likely to be
used as fishing nets in
those communities?
So that's, I think, what
most people would--
that would be your
initial instinct.
The problem you would have if
you did that, as opposed to--
sorry, can you remind
of your name?
AUDIENCE: [? Sif. ?]
ESTHER DUFLO: [? Sif. ?]
The problem to do that, as
opposed to do what [? Sif ?]
suggested, is to know why some
community happened to be the
one that got them for free and
some community happened not to
have the free distribution.
So let's think of one reason
why there might be a free--
if you were to start a free bed
net distribution program
somewhere, where would
you start it?
You have a country and you want
to start a free bed net
distribution, what
would you pick?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If there was
a particularly bad
increase, or something.
ESTHER DUFLO: Right.
You would try to pick a place
where there is a lot of
malaria, presumably, or
maybe a place where
people are very poor.
So let's work with the example
where you would pick, to start
your free bed net distribution,
the region where
there is a lot of malaria.
It would make sense.
So if that's the case that free
bed nets are distributed
where malaria is a huge problem,
then in these places,
even if they had to pay for the
bed net, they might have
purchased them more willingly
than in places where malaria
is not such a big
problem anyway.
Because the private benefits of
having a bed net is higher
in those [INAUDIBLE].
So this is what we call the
counter-factual, which is what
would have happened in the place
where the bed net got
distributed for free if they
had actually been sold.
So let's look at it in the
form of a simple graph.
So suppose we have two--
we are going to do the argument
for purchase, and the
same kind of discussion
we could have for use.
So suppose we have two regions,
a high-malaria region
and a low-malaria region.
And suppose that God told us
this is how many people would
buy a bed net, the fraction of
people who would buy a bed net
in the high-malaria region and
the low-malaria region, if the
bed net was not subsidized.
And this dot is higher, because
since malaria is more
of a problems, people are more
willing to buy bed nets.
OK?
So that's what we would have
if bed nets were expensive.
And if bed nets were free,
we would have those ones.
So compared to the previous
dots, they are higher.
Why are they higher
in both regions?
AUDIENCE: It's because
they're free.
ESTHER DUFLO: Because they're
free, so you're more likely to
get something free than
to have to pay for it.
But they are still higher in
the high-malaria region,
because why would you get a
bed net in a region where
malaria is not a problem?
You really don't need it.
If you don't have a fishing
boat, you don't need a fishing
net either.
So they are still higher in a
high-malaria region then in a
low-malaria region when
bed nets are free.
So this is what God would
have given you.
But sadly, God didn't
give you that.
God gave you either this
point or that point.
What you observe is the purchase
of bed nets in the
area where they are given for
free, and the purchase of bed
nets in the area where
they are expensive.
And those regions are different
because one is a
high-malaria region and one
is a low-malaria region.
So what you observe is the
demand for bed nets when they
are free in a high-malaria
region, and the demand for bed
nets when they're expense in
the low-malaria region.
And what you don't see
is those guys.
What you see is this and this.
What is the true effect of
price on purchase in the
high-malaria region?
Where do I find it
on the graph?
That's the vertical thing.
That's the true effect of free
versus expensive in the
high-malaria region.
And this is the true effect of
free versus expensive in the
low-malaria region.
So this is the true effect.
That's what I'm looking for.
Sadly, I don't have this,
and I don't have this.
I'm not in very good shape.
What I do have is
this and this.
So if I just did to comparison
that we started with, we would
compare the high-malaria region
purchase when it's free
to the low-malaria purchase
region when it's expensive.
Take the difference.
That would be our effect.
So is that the true effect?
Is it biased upwards, or
is it biased downwards?
Is that too big, too small,
or the right size?
AUDIENCE: Too big.
ESTHER DUFLO: Too big.
And we can see it here,
which we can re-put.
We can say, well, suppose we had
what God would have given
all the numbers.
In the low-malaria region, this
is the effect of price
and purchase.
And the rest is the best.
In the high-malaria region,
this is the true effect of
price and purchase, and
the rest is the bias.
So if we knew this and this, we
could calculate the effect,
and we calculate the bias that
we would get if we compare
this to this.
But suddenly, we don't
have those.
So what this is saying, in other
words, is that when we
compare purchase when it's free
to purchase when it's
expensive, in the high- and
low-malaria region, we combine
two effects.
We combine the effect that even
at the same price, the
purchase would have
been different.
So the counter-factual would
have been different--
those are this versus this,
and this versus this--
and the fact that there
is actually an effect.
So that's why it's not a very
good answer for the question
we're asking.
This we did for only two points,
but we would have the
same thing if we had
many price points.
So suppose this is the observed
demand at various prices--
when it's free, when it's 10
shilling, when it's 20
shilling, when it's
30 shilling.
That's the observed demand.
So someone could say, well,
I'm going to trace a line
here, and that's going to give
you my elasticity of purchase
with respect to the
price of the good.
Now, let's say if God had given
us the observed demand,
the demand we would observe in
the region with the free bed
net if the bed net were not
free, that's the demand we
would observe in this
highest-malaria region.
It also decreases with
price, but less
than we see in reality.
And why does it decrease less
than we see in the data, the
yellow dots?
So the yellow dots are
what we would see in
the high-price region--
so in the free region, what we
would see in the zero price
region, if the price were
in fact 10, 20, 30, 40.
So why is it flatter than
the observed curve?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Because it was
free, [INAUDIBLE].
ESTHER DUFLO: So this
is what is free?
This is a bit more.
This is the demand
when it's free.
It's very high.
This is in the next region,
where it costs 10 shilling.
It's a bit lower.
This point is telling us, this
is how many bed nets the
people in this region would
purchase if the price was, in
fact, 10 shilling instead
of being free.
So this and this and this,
we don't observe.
But we just say, let's say I'm
telling you this is God told
you what it would be.
The reason why it is higher is
because the region where it is
free is a region where people
need the malaria nets a lot.
So even if they had pay
10 shilling, they
would still buy them.
And even if they had pay
20 shilling, they
would still buy them.
And even if they had to pay 30
shilling, they would still buy
them, although less, because of
course they are sensitive
to the price.
But the difference between the
yellow point and the red point
is the yellow point is just
the effect of the price,
whereas the red point also has
the effect of the fact that
you're more likely to have to
pay for bed nets in places
where the malaria is not
such a big problem.
So the red dot, which is what
we observe in reality,
combines the effect of the price
and the fact that the
regions where people have
to pay are different.
Yeah, Ben?
AUDIENCE: The x-axis is price?
ESTHER DUFLO: The
x-axis is price.
Yeah, sorry.
I should have--
it's like this, 0, 10, 20, 30.
AUDIENCE: It's still not obvious
to me why if it's
free, if you go from zero to,
let's say, a million, why the
demand for free bed nets would
change [INAUDIBLE]?
ESTHER DUFLO: No, it's not the
demand for free bed nets.
This is always going to be the
demand at this price--
0, 10, 20.
So it's still declining,
you see?
AUDIENCE: No, I'm saying
for free bed nets.
ESTHER DUFLO: Oh.
For free, it's pretty high.
AUDIENCE: Why does it change
at all, if you go
from price 0 to 30--
ESTHER DUFLO: Oh, you're
wondering about this one.
You're wondering about
this point.
You're wondering, in the
low-malaria region, if I give
you a bed net for free,
why don't you get it?
AUDIENCE: Well, no.
Because the x-axis is high
instances of malaria, low
instances of malaria.
ESTHER DUFLO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You switched
the price.
I'm confused why changing how
much a free bed nets costs
would decrease the amount of
purchases for free bed nets.
ESTHER DUFLO: So what is a
little tricky is that there
are two things in the axis.
There is the fact that this is a
high-malaria region, and the
fact that it's a low-malaria
region.
And it turns out-- but this is
what is very important--
it turns out that the price
is related to the
incidence of malaria.
So here, for example, in the
two-region case, I have given
the bed net for free
in the region where
the malaria was high.
And the reason is because if I'm
a good policy maker and I
don't have that much money,
that's what I will do.
I will first give the bed net
for free in the region where
malaria is high.
And I will ask people to pay for
the bed net in the region
where malaria is low.
So what I observe in reality
is the demand for free bed
nets in the high-malaria region
and the demand for
expensive bed nets in the
low-malaria region.
So if I compare the difference
between the two,
and if I call this--
I'm combining two effects.
I'm combining the effect of the
price, which is, given the
same region, people are more
likely to get a bed net for
free than to pay for it, and
the fact that people, given
that bed nets are more useful
in a region where there is a
lot of malaria than
in a region where
there is little malaria.
People are more likely to get
bed nets at any price--
the red dots are for
the same price--
at any price, people will be
more likely to get bed nets in
the high-malaria region than
in the low-malaria region.
So if you compare within a line
the yellow to the red
dot, you get the effect
of the price.
If you compare across columns
within the same color, you get
the effect of being in high-
versus low-malaria region.
And you see they tend to go in
the same direction, which is
what creates your bias.
All right, do you get the
two-region, two-prices example?
If you get the two-region,
two-prices example, then this
one is the same, but
with four prices.
Now we have four regions--
a region where we give them for
free, a region where we
give them for 10 shilling, a
region where we give them for
20 shilling, a region where we
give them for 30 shilling.
And this is what I observe in
reality, a very steep slope.
At 30, almost no one buys it.
But this is due, again,
to two things.
One is that that's expensive.
So even if malaria was a real
problem, people would be less
likely to buy them for 30.
And, in addition, those regions
where people had to
pay a lot of money for malaria
is precisely because malaria
is not such a big problem
in those regions.
So in order to decompose those
two effects, what I'm doing is
that I'm playing God and I'm
telling you, this is what the
demand at various prices would
have been in this first
region, in the zero region, in
the high-malaria region.
So this I don't see
in reality.
In the world, I don't see that,
but this is what it
would have been.
And it's a little flatter
than this one because
this is like the bias.
This is saying, these are places
which don't really need
malaria, and this is the
effect of prices.
The yellow one is a true effect
of prices, and the
vertical lines are the bias
that are added by the fact
that prices are expensive in
places where a bed net is not
very useful because malaria is
not so much of a problem.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Why is there not a bias based
on your environment and how
much malaria there is when
they're for free?
ESTHER DUFLO: Well, when they're
for free, we observe
the true demand at free.
So that happens to be the same
point, which is, I'm giving
you what I observe.
And the free region is the
demand when it's free.
What I would like to know, then,
is what would the demand
in the free region be if, in
fact, it had been 10 shilling?
So this is this counter-factual,
which is,
there is something we don't
observe, which is precisely
what we need to compare
to the region where,
in fact, it is free.
Ask as many questions
as you have.
The more questions, the better.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
why [INAUDIBLE]
more likely to go from
zero to 10 shillings.
Do you see that the [INAUDIBLE]
decrease in the
[INAUDIBLE]
ESTHER DUFLO: So you have--
so what is your name?
AUDIENCE: Katja.
ESTHER DUFLO: Again?
ESTHER DUFLO: Katja.
Katja has a question, which is,
she doesn't believe that
the elasticity is the
way I drew it.
You think that it's more like
steep and then flatter?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ESTHER DUFLO: Possibly.
That's the way I made that up.
I consider that zero and 10 is
kind of similar, but that has
no reason to be true.
And substantially, you're
absolutely right.
It could be that, in fact, there
is a big drop in demand.
But then the red point would
probably be even lower.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why were the
experiments conducted so that
you only get the orange
data points?
Why did you not mix up different
communities that
have had malaria and
[INAUDIBLE] malaria
[? for each-- ?]
ESTHER DUFLO: That's
an excellent point.
So this is not supposed to have
come from an experiment.
This is the real world.
[INAUDIBLE]
a real world outside
of an experiment.
And outside of an experiment
in the real
world, it is likely--
it doesn't have to be the case,
but it's likely that
policy maker will make the bed
net available for free in
high-malaria region, because
it makes sense for them.
But your question exactly brings
to what the answer to
the problem is.
So we have a problem, which is
that we observe the low prices
in places where the need is
high, and high prices in the
regions where they need
is low, so that
leads to this bias.
And the solution is exactly what
you suggested, which is,
let's have variation in prices
in regions where
the need is the same.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So on the x-axis, are
you exactly correlating
the price of the bed nets with
the incidence of malaria, or--
ESTHER DUFLO: So what I'm
assuming, I'm telling you this
doesn't have to be true.
And the problem is we'll never
know, because we won't observe
both in the real world.
But I'm telling you this happens
to be like that in
this particular fictional world
that I constructed,
where this was like that.
AUDIENCE: But if you go along
the x-axis to the right, you
mean that bed nets get more
expensive and malaria
incidence goes up?
ESTHER DUFLO: Goes down.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry,
goes down?
ESTHER DUFLO: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ESTHER DUFLO: I constructed
it that way.
You could construct the opposite
example, and you
could make up a story where the
richer regions have more
political power, and they
also have less malaria.
So the richer region will get
the free bed nets, and they
will also have less malaria.
In that case, where would the
observed compared to the true
elasticity, where would the red
dot be, if, in fact, the
correlation was the other way?
AUDIENCE: They would
go the other way?
ESTHER DUFLO: They would
go the other way.
So the red dot would be above,
because the bed nets are more
expensive where they
are more needed.
And your question brings in an
essential question, which is,
sadly, we can't know.
We can know some stuff, which
is we can, for example,
measure malaria prevalence.
But we never observe the
counter-factual.
So either we observe the demand,
where the price is
high, in the places where it's
high, or we observe the demand
where the price is low in the
places where it's low.
And we never get to see the
demand where the price is low
in the places where it's high.
That's the missing data point.
That's why this is what
we are missing.
In other words, we don't see
those yellow points.
We don't see what the demand
would have been in a zero
price region if the price, in
fact, had been 10, 20, 30.
We just don't know.
So the solution is what you
suggested, which is to say,
why don't we take one region and
try to vary the prices in
those regions?
Or in fact, we could take two
regions, a high-malaria region
and a low-malaria region,
and vary the prices
in those two regions.
And this is where the word
experiment comes up.
This is where the experiment is,
which is the way you would
do it to be completely sure that
there is no difference
between the places or the people
which got the bed net
for free, and the places or
people which had to pay for
it, is you would randomly assign
the price of the bed
net to different regions or
two different people.
So this is what is done, for
example, in medicine when you
want when you want
to find out the
effectiveness of a new drug.
You don't give the new drug to
people who need it the most.
Otherwise, you would
find that the drug
killed a lot of people.
You take some part of people
who need the drug, and you
randomly assign some people to
take the drug and some people
to get the placebo.
You might also take a sample
of people who need the drug
less, and randomly assign the
drug within them, to find out
side effect if you
misprescribe.
But you wouldn't give the drug
to people who need it, and not
the drug to people who don't
need it, otherwise all of the
drugs would be sure to
kill a lot of people.
So most evaluation of social
policy is trying to estimate
the effect of policies by
doing these kind of
comparisons, this point
to this point.
And that creates this
bias situation.
And in fact, you can try and
make more progress on this
question by creating experiments
where you fix the
region, or you fix the
environment, and you randomly
assign the prices.
The randomization ensures
that there is nothing
systematically different between
the people who got the
free bed net and people
who didn't get it.
In other words, there is no--
if we go back to this graph, for
example, the places that
got the free bed net and the
places that had to pay for the
bed net, if they had gotten it
for free, they would be at the
same level.
And if they had pay
for it, they would
be at the same level.
There is now no difference
between the region who paid
for the net and the region who
didn't pay for the net.
One point before going into the
results of what Cohen, and
then Pascaline Dupas found for
the bed net is that of course,
this is not true if it's just
one village and another
village, like Steve suggested.
Why is it, if we took only one
village, and in one case we
make free, one case we make not
free-- we can flip a coin,
and then we compare--
why is that problematic?
Two villages--
why is two villages
not enough?
AUDIENCE: Because you can't make
sure that everything is
the same [INAUDIBLE]
like one village might
have more [INAUDIBLE]
actually care about each other,
or one village might
end up having a really rainy
season, so all the mosquitoes
happen to swamp around it.
ESTHER DUFLO: Exactly.
Two villages, even if there
is nothing systematically
different, because you've thrown
a coin, so you didn't
choose one village rather
than the other for their
characteristic to give the bed
net for free or to ask people
to pay for them.
Even in that case, there are
things that are different
across villages that you
can't fully control.
So you need the samples to be
large enough such that all the
other differences between people
or between regions
average out, so that even though
you do not observe what
the demand for bed net would
have been in the free region
when actually you ask people to
pay for it, you would not
observe that.
But you can be confident that
what the demand you observe in
the other region where it was
free gives you the right
counter-factual.
And for that, the sample needs
to be large enough so that all
the noise and the idiosyncrasies
get swamped.
So let's look at two sets
of experiments.
Both were Pascaline Dupas, who
is a professor at UCLA, was is
involved in both of them.
The first one was conducted
with Jessica Cohen.
In and around this
place, which is
called Busia in Kenya.
This hotel, you can see that the
beginning of the hotel is
called "Blue York," where
I spent a lot of time.
And so what did they do?
They randomly chose clinics,
prenatal clinics, they gave
them nets to give to people who
come for their prenatal
exam, either at zero or
20 shilling or 30
shilling or 40 shilling.
So the unit of randomization
is the clinic.
And then they compare how many
bed nets they sold, and
whether the bed net got used,
and therefore the effective
coverage in those clinics.
And this is what they find.
So the little vertical
line here is
the confidence interval.
So it's taking into account
all the noise that
exists in the data.
And so what is the conclusion
from this graph, at free, 10
shilling, 20 shilling,
40 shilling?
This is the number of nets
sold per week, I think.
AUDIENCE: Does that indicate if
the customers actually use
the bed net?
ESTHER DUFLO: No.
So far, this is the first look
at, which is just how many bed
nets were given out.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the demand curves downward.
ESTHER DUFLO: The demand curves
downward, and it's
quite steep, right?
Basically, at 40 shilling,
which is still heavily
subsidized, because the full
price of a bed net is more
like 80 shilling, you distribute
only about 10 bed
nets per week, versus 40
per week, when you
give them for free.
So it goes down quite steeply.
And I remember, because they
were randomly selected, we
know that it is due to the
price, and not due to
differences across
those regions.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That's funny, because the error
bars are pretty big.
Like, if you if you looked at
the lower error, versus the
higher error, it's
[INAUDIBLE].
ESTHER DUFLO: So you take this
one compared to this one.
That's the confidence
interval.
So we are 95% confident that
the truth is somewhere in
between there.
That the 95 confidence interval,
[INAUDIBLE].
Right?
So you can know that this
is systematically
different from this.
You're right that this
and this, the
confidence interval overlaps.
And in fact, the numbers
are quite similar.
This is why I don't answer
someone who was asking why
didn't I draw the elasticity
that way I'd drawn it that
way, because I already knew the
answer to the question.
I was ahead of the
game, slightly.
So zero to 10 is not such
a big difference.
Maybe 10 is not that
expensive.
But 40 is definitely different
from free.
You're right.
Certainly we would like those
bars to be smaller.
If we had more observations,
they would be.
They would be even
more precise.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Were the clinics far
apart from each other?
It could be, say, I'd go to the
clinic where I'd have to
pay 20 shillings [INAUDIBLE]
ESTHER DUFLO: Right.
That's a very good point.
The people shift from one
clinic to the other.
So they couldn't really do that,
because the clinics were
quite far away.
On the other hand, what they did
find is a lot more people
coming to the clinic, presumably
to get the bed net,
which is a good thing, because
it cost subsidizes other
services that you get
in the clinic, in
particular a test for HIV.
And if the mother is HIV
positive, then you can give
them Nevirapine just before the
delivery to prevent the
transmission to the
[INAUDIBLE].
So that's another story, which
is a reason why you might want
to distribute bed nets
if people like them.
Now, this was your question,
which is, but are people are
using them?
And so far, the usage, you can
ask people what they tell you.
But they could lie.
Or you can try and go to their
home and see whether you see
the bed net.
And here, what's
the conclusion?
So this is conditional, having
gotten a bed net.
So what they did that they
took the register.
They saw who got a bed net, and
they went to their home
and said, what are you doing
with the bed net?
Is it a fishing net or are you
using it for a bed net?
And what do they find?
AUDIENCE: What's the y-axis?
ESTHER DUFLO: So it's percentage
divided by 10.
So it's 0%, 20%, 40%,
60%, 80%, 100%.
Ben?
AUDIENCE: I'm a little confused
about the why.
So 10 is interesting to me, like
why 50% of the people who
purchase the bed nets actually
use the bed nets.
ESTHER DUFLO: So a bit more,
it's more like 60%.
AUDIENCE: For 10?
ESTHER DUFLO: Yeah,
for 10 shilling.
It's about 60%.
AUDIENCE: Can you help
me understand
why that trend happens?
ESTHER DUFLO: Oh, why
is it going down?
AUDIENCE: Right.
ESTHER DUFLO: It's not--
I mean, going back to the
question earlier, it's not
significantly different.
So it's kind of all similar.
So overall, about the trend,
what do you have to say?
This is pretty similar.
It seems pretty flat.
So there is no very big evidence
that how much of paid
for a bed net influenced whether
or not you're going to
use it or not.
And it's not 100%.
It's more like towards 60%
to 70%, so not everybody
uses the bed net.
But how much they pay for it
doesn't affect whether or not
they use it or not.
Interestingly, when they went
back six months to a year
later, more people are
likely to use them.
So some people just took them
because they were free, maybe,
or they were not very expensive,
and decided to
store them for future
usage, which is also
something you can do.
So people do not seem to not use
the bed net because they
got them for free.
And the result is that if you
look at the effective
coverage, the effective coverage
is very strongly
declining with price.
So the conclusion from their
study is that you should give
the bed nets for free, because
you get many more bed nets
out, you're much more
likely to go--
if you get them for free,
you're going to
be above 60% coverage.
And once you go above 60%
coverage, you're more likely
to buy them.
But before you go, I want
to give you the
epilogue, which is--
so this is the reading I asked
you to see, which is people--
so this got posted on Daniel
Roderick's blog, under the
title "Jeff Sachs Vindicated,"
which is to say, oh, yeah, we
should give bed nets for free.
This experiment showed that.
And then people complained,
and said, this is only
pregnant women, and pregnant
women all need the bed net, so
they are going to use
it at any price.
The sunk cost effect won't be
there for pregnant women.
And secondly, it's Kenya, where
bed nets are still quite
well-known.
So what are people objecting?
People are objecting to saying,
the experiment gives
you a lot of internal
validity.
We know now that in the specific
context of clinics in
western Kenya with pregnant
mothers, there is no effect of
the price you pay on
whether you use.
But maybe this doesn't apply
to Uganda, Maybe it doesn't
affect non-pregnant women,
et cetera, et cetera.
So this is a question of
external validity.
So what's the solution?
When these kind of questions
are raised, what's the
solution to make progress?
You've can't ignore
these questions.
They are very good questions.
What's the solution
to make progress?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Try it
in other areas.
ESTHER DUFLO: You want to
try it in other areas.
So in fact, in bed nets,
this got done.
So this got tried first in
different countries, so in
Uganda, in Madagascar.
And secondly, it got tried in
Kenya, but as I was going to
say, real people, not pregnant
women, but people from the
market, men and women.
And here, vouchers got given
at various prices to
individuals for them to pick
them up in the shop.
So now this is an environment
where have you would have
expected to be more likely to
find a sunk cost effect.
Moreover, the experiment was
also done to look at these
longer-term consequences.
So after six months, they went
back again to the same people,
and tried to sell them a bed net
for 100 shillings, so not
the lowest price, and not
the highest price.
And so the question is, the
people who got the first bed
net for free, are they more
likely to buy the second one
for 100 shilling, or are they
less likely to buy the second
one for 100 shilling?
So I'll run you to the
result quickly.
So they find the same effect of
price on purchase, that the
more you pay, the less you
get, quite steeply.
They find the same lack
of effect of price
on whether you use.
And so this is not pregnant
woman anymore.
So this kind of generalizes
a bit the result.
And this is the effect on
future approaches, the
confidence bar, a
little bit high.
But if anything, what you find
is that people are more likely
to buy a second bed net when
they got it for free or almost
free than when they
were offered the
option to pay for one.
And this is despite the fact
that at that time, they
already had a bed net.
So presumably, their need for
a second bed net is less so.
So it seems that the learning
effect dominates the
entitlement effect.
So if we go back to the
wrecking market story,
sustainability question you
could say, well actually,
giving a sweep of bed nets for
free might be a good way to
create a market.
Because you create a demand
among people who start
learning and say, actually,
it's kind of nice,
that bed nets idea.
The last way in which you create
a demand is by creating
this first user of a bed net.
So this is the last card that
I'm going to show you.
This is the purchase of a bed
net if you have to pay for it
if none of your neighbors
got it for free.
And this is a purchase of a bed
net, if you had to pay for
it, if all of your neighbors
got it for free.
And that is randomly assigned,
because depending on who your
neighbors are, where they are
located, what kind of voucher
they get, this is just random
whether they get this one.
And what you see is that if your
neighbor got bed nets for
free, you're more likely
to get one.
So there is actually a positive
social effect.
So the reason why I wanted
detail into this experiment is
that that's an experiment that
shows us how we can use
experiments not only to evaluate
the impact of a
policy, but the answer those
questions that help us
understand how people decide
whether the entitlement effect
is bigger or smaller than the
learning effect, whether the
sunk cost fallacy exists,
whether how the big the price
elasticities are, et cetera.
And we need to design
the experiment to
answer all those questions.
And then we can start informing
the policy debate.
Sorry for running over.